[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Qui a dit que tout était perdu
je viens offrir mon coeur
tant de sang que la rivière a emporté
Ce ne sera pas si facile, je sais ce qui se passe
ce ne sera pas aussi simple que je le pensais
comment ouvrir le pied
Je sors l'âme
un couteau
d'amour
un des pauvres toujours ouvert
et je viens offrir mon coeur
comme un document inaltérable
je viens offrir mon coeur
et une des extrémités d'une même boucle
et j'irai tranquillement j'irai doucement
et je te donnerai tout
et veux-tu me donner quelque chose
quelque chose qui me soulage un peu plus
quand il n'y a rien de près ou de loin
je viens offrir mon coeur
quand les satellites ne m'atteignent pas
Je viens offrir mon coeur et je parle de
pays et d'espoir je parle pour la vie
je parle pour rien
et je parle de changer notre maison
pour le changer pour changer normal
dit que tout est perdu
je viens offrir mon coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
un
[Musique]
J'ai tellement de frères
je ne peux pas avec eux
[Musique]
dans la basse la montagne
sur l'écran et dans le pain
chacun avec ses obstacles
avec leurs rêves chacun
en espérant devant
avec les souvenirs de derrière que j'ai
tellement de frères que je ne peux pas
[Musique]
un
Oui
[Musique]
gens chauds
pour cela
d'amitié
avec une chorale pour pleurer
avec une prière pour prier avec un horizon
ouvert
c'est toujours au-delà
[Musique]
et cette force de chercher
avec ténacité et volonté
bien qu'il semble plus proche, c'est quand
m'éloigner plus j'ai tellement de frères que
Je ne peux pas
oh
[Musique]
et ainsi nous continuons pour vous
de solitude
on se perd dans le monde
On se revoit
et ainsi nous continuons à marcher pour toi de la solitude
et en nous nos morts
pour que personne ne soit laissé pour compte
J'ai tellement de frères
que je ne peux pas les compter et une erreur
pour qu'il soit
[Musique]
liberté
[Applaudissements]
Aujourd'hui je retourne à la frontière
doit repasser
est ce que le vent
m'envoie
qui me pousse à la frontière et est venu à la
manière que
[Musique]
Tu remarqueras
Endesa
arrêt
que veux-tu être
sur ce mur
je
tu me traînes le ciel et les nuages
d'hiver
le vent quoi
mains
et il n'y a personne qui
semble parfois impitoyable
[Musique]
parfois
oh
[Musique]
Oui
passé la frontière aujourd'hui
Maxwell est vrai
sous le ciel
C'est le vent qui sous le ciel
mais je suis
oh
le sol
[Musique]
au
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lis
la rue
ne pas
[Musique]
variété
je
Oh
Oui
[Musique]
avec wade il lui a donné asile mais aussi stable
mètres seront
ils sont coupables
[Musique]
la vie de ton fils tu chies nous sommes arrivés
soulever m pense que parce qu'ils sont coupables
[Musique]
à penser
permettre
pour moi
je
père
que vous savez qu'il est émis
prix segi que le para militaire
[Musique]
Soleil
de la gestion de macri
[Musique]
oh
à présent
l'heure
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup des prix
zsolt besoin ou retarder ma part de
la monture est pour la réflexion si c'est ça
une fois
que se passe-t-il
[Applaudissements]
recevoir des instructions vocales
haut-parleurs
c'était un jour qu'ils évacuent ils craquent
s
ils ne se font jamais prendre je m'inscris pour en savoir plus ils veulent
passer
oui oui c'est vrai que oui
oui au maximum
de leurs enfants, amis, c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
regarde apprendre à considérer et aussi
savoir accuser le regard final
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du regard
regarder
[Musique]
à envisager
le rouge le rosier éparpille les cinq lo
mais certains regardent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Pourquoi pas
détrompez-vous les gens ivres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]